nothing stays still
but the south side of Glasgow has become
very used to Nicholas sturgeon even if
they don't all agree with her
she's done a great job um taking on the
Tories
um nobody else uses fun with the boys
hot and showing all our opponents for
the past eight years out showing them
all what do you think her Legacy will be
has got me she's the longest server a
failure yeah NHS is a mess schools
education
thank you that already through covert I
think she did her best
um but it just feels like that was our
Peak and it's all just kind of went a
little bit down pill from there
Nicholas sturgeon says she wants a more
normal life but will still represent
glasgow's south side and fights her
political battles from here including of
course the snp's push for Independence
hi guys welcome to the Future opinion
polls still have Scotland split down the
middle at imran's restaurant he sees the
current first Minister as integral to
Independence I feel as if
with her departing like this it's going
to crumble
why
I think purely because she was the
backbone to this Pro referendum
pro-independence you know and um now
with her departure it's all will come
down crumbly evening drinks at the Bell
jar Malcolm helps run the yes campaign
in this part of the city what it does is
introduce a degree of uncertainty in how
things will be in the short term I mean
I think Nicola's going in her own terms
um and uh
and she feels that she's a divisive
figure for people who don't want
independence and therefore maybe it will
open the door to more people coming over
to Independence uh time will tell
in the city center those who said no to
Independence held a brief Street party
this Minister has to somehow represent
and serve everyone
after eight years on this ride it's time
for someone else
Tom Parmenter Sky News Glasgow